stocks are plunging as investors
scramble over a potential trade war with
China while President Trump talks tough
on trade we examine the case for tariffs
so many conservatives still fail to
understand the case for tariffs then
twenty20 Democratic presidential
candidate but a judge attacks president
Trump's marriage because Pete but a
judge is a jerk I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mayor Pete's such a nice guy isn't he's
got that nice face beautiful big blue
eyes he's a good old boys get except
he's not he's a huge jerk and he keeps
demonstrating this every single day so
we will analyze but first if you don't
know your numbers you don't know your
business
the problem with growing businesses is
that they the sometimes they don't know
their numbers because of their
hodgepodge of business systems I know
this I've been involved in a number of
businesses as they've started up and I'm
not exactly a numbers guy and I'm not
exactly the most organized fella in the
world and it becomes a mess and you can
lose a lot of money you can lose a lot
of time you can lose your business so
you may be a business has one system for
accounting another for sales another for
inventory and it's just an inefficient
mess takes up too much time too many
resources hurts the bottom line
introducing NetSuite by Oracle the
business management software that
handles every aspect of your business in
an easy-to-use cloud platform giving you
the visibility and control you need to
grow even if I had known about NetSuite
when I was starting one of my first
business right out of college it
probably would have turned out better
than it did
NetSuite you will save you time money
unneeded headaches by managing sales
Finance and Accounting orders an HR
instantly right from your desktop or
phone that's why NetSuite is the world's
number one cloud business system right
now NetSuite is offering you valuable
insights with a free guide seven key
strategies to grow your profits and
NetSuite comm slash Knowles canna wles
don't be a dummy go over there right now
check out the free guide NetSuite
dot-com slash Knowles canna wles
download the guide seven key strategies
to grow your profits what have you got
to lose nothing
NetSuite comm slash Knowles Pete Buddy
judges at jerk no other way to put it
what Pete but a judge is a totally
unknown guy he was the mayor of a small
town in Indiana he's announced that he's
running for president and we're told by
everybody he's so nice he's got so much
dignity he's got so much integrity he's
a boy scout he's going to be the
positive candidate what have we actually
seen him done
for or what have we actually seen him do
so far he attacked Mike Pence basically
called Mike Pence a bigot why I don't
know Mike Pence has only ever said nice
things about Pete but a judge when Pete
but a judge deployed to Afghanistan Mike
Pence personally called him to wish him
well when Pete but a judge came out as a
gay guy Mike Pence said Pete but a judge
I have the utmost respect for he's a
patriot he's a great guy and I really
like him and then Pete but a judge
announces he's running for president and
he goes after Mike Pence and he says
Mike Pence is this sort of bigoted then
what we've seen Pete but a judge come
out and Christian questioned the faith
of other Christians we've now seen him
attack president Trump's marriage
completely unprovoked it's not as though
president Trump was going after but a
judge but a judge goes after him this
really personal nasty way and now but a
judge is saying that Republicans are
also bad Christians is it jerk he's
nasty I don't like him you know they
were all told is this sweet little guy
and he's so mean-spirited no major
figure on the right has attacked Pete
but a judge's romantic relationships
show me one who has gone after Pete but
a judge because of his sexual
preferences or his domestic life I don't
think you're gonna find one but Pete but
a judge is going after others for that
exact same thing here is Pete but a
judge going after president Trump's
marriage look my emotions about this
president are not what's going to matter
most I'm not interested in expressing my
anger about him as much as I am in
defeating and ending his presidency we
want to have a debate with him a fight
over any number of things from the
difference between you know the way I
approach service and the way he did the
fact that I was packing my bags for
Afghanistan while he was working on
season seven of Celebrity Apprentice we
can have that fight it's not just you
know somebody wants to raise a question
of which one of us has a more
traditional attitude on marriage we can
have that fight but at the end of the
day it's not about him it's not about me
it is about you not you but our host is
evening but you the American voters it's
if someone wants to raise that question
of nobody's raising that question
someone wants to raise the question of
service someone wants to raise the
question of marriage nobody's raising
that question except for you Pete but a
judge it's not about me also so his
first attack on Trump that but a judge
was packing up for Afghanistan well
Trump was doing season 7 of The
Apprentice does but a judge think Donald
Trump should have been listed in the
army at age 62 is that what he's really
suggesting I guess he could go after
President Trump for getting deferments
from Vietnam that would be if he
actually wants to have an attack on
Donald Trump for dodging military
service he should go after him for not
fighting in Vietnam
why isn't Pete but a judge doing that is
because he's gonna need the support of a
lot of other draft dodgers so he's gonna
need this Bill Clinton is a great
example Democrats nominated a guy and
re-elected him he was served two terms
as president Bill Clinton who was a
draft dodger maybe he's gonna want Bill
Clinton's support eventually so he's not
going to go after the draft dodger issue
not going to go after a lot of other
Democrat senators maybe ex senators
governors so he goes after him on
Afghanistan weaksauce but then to go
after a man's marriage is really really
nasty he's not just saying Donald Trump
speaks badly about women Donald Trump
treats women badly no he's saying Donald
Trump's marriage is somehow wrong
somehow not traditional by the way it's
not true Donald Trump has a more
traditional view of marriage than Pete
but a judge why doesn't Donald Trump
have a traditional marriage
well he's cheated on his wives cheating
on your wife is very traditional it's
it's not good it's wrong to cheat on
your wife but it is a very traditional
adultery plays central roles in the
Iliad in the Odyssey in the book of
Genesis you know all of human history
adultery has played a big role it's very
traditional it's bad but it's
traditional well he's gotten divorced a
lot of people have gotten divorced the
law of Moses allows for divorce as
Christ discusses in the New Testament
and disapproves of well
we got divorced right the Church of
England was founded on a guy who wanted
to get a divorce
very traditional wrong but very
traditional well he's he slept with a
porn star right uh-huh
I know this yes sometimes rich powerful
men cheat on their wives and that's a
terrible thing Donald Trump still holds
a more traditional view of marriage than
Pete but a judge Pete but a judge might
be monogamous he might go to church
every Sunday the traditional view of
marriage for all of human history until
five minutes ago was that sexual
complementarity sexual difference is
essential to marriage that marriage is
the union of husbands and wives now
maybe it's one husband and ten wives in
certain ancient cultures but always
husbands and wives and really for the
span of Western civilization that we're
talking about over the last two thousand
years
we're talking about one husband and one
wife Christian marriage one husband and
one wife sexual complementarity has in
heerd in all definitions of marriage for
all of human history until about five
minutes ago
so even if Pete but a judge is a really
good guy if his new definition of
marriage says that that sexual
difference doesn't matter it is
necessarily less traditional now Pete
but a judge might make the argument that
same-sex marriage is actually better
it's more virtuous it's more holy it's
more Christian he can try to make that
argument if he wants that's not the
argument that he just made though what
he's saying is his views of marriage is
more more traditional than Donald
Trump's that just isn't true and Pete
but a judge isn't just going after Trump
he's going after all Republicans it all
sussed been a fair amount of time
talking about your faith it's
it's important of it and I think it's
also important that we stop seeing
religion
used as a kind of culture as it as if
God belonged to a political party and if
you did I can't imagine it would be the
one that sent the current president in
the White House oh what a jerk I listen
I think we need to stop pretending that
God belongs to a political party and
realize that God is a Democrat okay I'm
mayor Pete I'm a really nice guy I'm
from Indiana
I'm just come on let's just common sense
God does not belong to a political party
also he's obviously a Democrat that's
what he's saying
again nobody on the right has said God
is a Republican God is not a Republican
God is not he God is not an American
partisan God is a king of all of
creation he has his own Kingdom but what
Pete but a judge is doing by saying that
God is not a Republican is implying
maybe God is a Democrat what he's
implying more to the point is that
Republicans are bad Christians he's more
or less saying God would be a Democrat
this is a bad strategy for Pete Buddha
judge who is a big jerk we'll explain
why in a second but first hiring is
challenging and there is one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart a place where growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates in that
place is zip recruiter dot-com / Knowles
Keo wles
zip recruiter does so much zip recruiter
sends your job to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards and they don't just
stop there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them to apply to
your job so when you're looking at
different services to hire people you
can either do the one where you throw
spaghetti at the wall and say I hope
someone good sees this at some point or
you can use zip recruiter which oh so
many services zip recruiter which
actually goes out there proactively
finds people who would be a good match
they analyzed they spotlight the top
candidates so that you never miss a
great match they invite them to apply to
your job it's so effective that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter fourth
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter dot-com / null scanner wles
that is zip recruiter dot-com / Knowles
kena wles zip recruiter dot-com /
Knowles the smartest way to hire this I
think is a bad move for Buddha judge his
professed Christian faith is a big
advantage in this race you'll notice all
of these Democrats are running as far
left intersectional secular as they
possibly can
Buddha judge has this kind of Midwest
Christian charm about him so that is an
advantage but it's not an advantage if
he starts mocking the faith of every
other Christian or criticizing the faith
of every other Christian ridiculing even
the fact that he's gay
we've never had a gay president we've
never had a gay presidential candidate I
think he could get over that issue but I
don't think he can get over the issue if
he plays the victim constantly this is
the big mistake that he's making so what
Buddha judge is thinking is the only way
that he can possibly distinguish himself
in this field of 2122 candidates is if
he plays the victim if everyone is
embracing this intersectional victimhood
grievance mentality Buddha judge says
well gosh I'm an Ivy league-educated
military veteran Rhodes Scholar white
male privileged the only way that I can
pretend to be a victim is to play up my
gay grievances that's what he's thinking
this will kill him in the long run and
it probably won't even help him in the
short run consider two examples here
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama we had
never had a black president we'd never
had a serious black presidential
candidate Barack Obama comes out does
Barack Obama play the racial victim card
no no basically never does he play the
racial victim card he is big speech that
he gave in 2004 at the Democratic
National Convention he comes out he says
there's no white America there is no
black America there's the United States
of America there's no red America no
blue America no yellow purple
rainbow sprinkles no he's all just
uniting he's coming together I'm not
gonna play the victim I'm the inspiring
candidate hope and change now compare
that to Hillary Clinton who by the way
lost to him Hillary Clinton comes out
and it's wham wham wam I'm a woman
everyone hates me because I'm a woman I
can't do anything because I'm a woman
wha-wha-wha meanwhile Hillary Clinton's
entire political career exists because
she married Bill Clinton her husband
gave her her entire political career he
handed her a Senate seat from New York
he gave her a presidential campaign
he he gave her through all of that the
Secretary of State role and she and she
says why why I'm a woman I I can't do
anything everyone's keeping me down and
she lost she lost twice because people
hate that it's so annoying it's so [ __ ]
Oh everybody's got a problem
everybody's got a problem guys everybody
goes through hardship everybody
struggles there's a great line in a play
by Tennessee Williams called Orpheus
descending and you got this kind of
vagabond guy wandering through town he's
trying to trying to get a room at this
woman's house and he's trying to seduce
her and you know stay there for the
night and she's having none of it he
says but I got nowhere to go and she
says well everybody's got a problem and
that's yours yeah everybody's got
hardship everybody struggles so you can
either whine about it all the time or
you can show some grit and determination
the American people like dignity they
like suffering silently they like grit
they don't want whiny and little brats
which is what you saw from the Hillary
Clinton campaign that's what you're
seeing now from Pete Budaj
he really could offer youthful
Midwestern optimism he could he's very
smart he served his country he could do
he could offer that he's throwing it
away on this intersectional gambit that
is probably not going to pay off so then
he becomes this nasty catty jerk and he
loses the only thing that people
actually like
about him it also reminds us this theme
that just keeps coming back again and
again which is the left is always
projecting Pete Buddha judge for the
last few weeks has been accusing
conservative Christians of being
closed-minded and vindictive and
judgmental and there the Mike Pence's of
the world and God wouldn't be a
Republican and WHAM what what is he
doing he's doing all the things that
he's accusing conservative Christians of
doing he's questioning other people's
faith he's judging them their actions
and their faith he's been nasty he's
been cruel he's been uncompassionate
he's doing all the things he's accusing
them of doing that's not just footages
you remember that Pennsylvania guy that
we talked about yesterday that guy Brian
Simms Pennsylvania has of
Representatives member he was the guy
who goes out and starts screaming at
this woman who was protesting at a
Planned Parenthood and mocking her
appearance and harassing her and trying
to film her so it turns out he's back
but this time he's not mocking women of
a certain age instead he is trying to
Doc's three teenage girls here he is hi
everyone
representative Brian Sims here and I am
outside the Planned Parenthood at
southeastern Pennsylvania
oh no they're leaving now oh we've got
here a bunch of protestors a bunch of
pseudo Christian protestors who've been
out here shaming young girls for being
here continues the deal I've got $100 to
anybody who will identify any of these
three don't need to plan to look there's
nothing about what you're doing nothing
Christian at all about what you're doing
I nothing Christian or loving or God
about what you're doing so I've got $100
to anybody will identify $100 see if you
got some friends out here a hundred
bucks
it'd be easier if you just give me your
name your address where you from
rich what makes you think that it's your
job to tell women what's right for their
body and the truth is I'm not really
asking because I don't care shame on you
oh what a wacko so he first goes up and
offers a hundred dollars to get the the
identities and the addresses of three
teenage girls imagine if I did that just
by way of comparison I would not be
allowed within 150 yards of any the
schools or public grounds if I did that
but this guy who is an elected
representative in Pennsylvania goes out
no consequence
no banned from Twitter no censure from
the Pennsylvania House of
Representatives no nothing it's okay
he's allowed to go do that so then he
goes out and he says it's these three
white women teenage girls now he's white
but he uses white as this insult and
what's funny is one of the girls is not
white she's saying I'm not white I'm
Hispanic I'm not but he doesn't really
care about that so then he sort of
chases them away then he turns to
another guy who's protesting and he says
I'm gonna get your information so you
should just tell me who you are now and
the guy in perfect humility says oh this
is my name says yeah where are you from
says I'm from this place total humility
and he says well why do you think it's
good to protest Planned Parenthood and
then Brian Simms does what the left
always does he says I don't want to hear
the answer I'm gonna run away why
because he knows that he can't win a
battle of ideas he's he's ranting and
raving about how it's so great to kill
babies and how it's awful to not kill
babies he says there's nothing Christian
about not killing babies I recommend he
should try reading the Bible because the
Bible has a few things to say about this
or just any sort of moral philosophy at
all but he's ranting and raving and
accusing people and being cruel and
harass
calling them names and then he
approaches a man who has total humility
and who he knows is going to give him an
argument and then all of a sudden he
runs away because he can't take it a
couple lessons here one is this is we
should approach our political
disagreements the way that that last guy
did there the last guy that Brian Simms
is talking to who's just there he's
totally calm he's totally collected it
says well yeah this is my name if I'm
happy to answer any questions that you
have well it's bad to kill babies
because babies are people so we
shouldn't slaughter babies because
they're babies they're humans they're
living they haven't had due process
they're innocent and we shouldn't rip
them out of their mothers wombs or leave
them to die on an operating table that's
what he was going to say and that guy
Brian Simms the representative from
Pennsylvania he knew that there was
going to be a debate that he is not able
to engage in so he runs away from it
that's very telling that shows you a
whole lot now the the reason that he
keeps making the rounds right now is
because of the censorship that's been
going on on social media
you've got parity accounts being
censored you've got conservatives being
censored you got all sorts of people
being censored and that guy is allowed
to keep his Twitter account which he
uses explicitly to harass humiliate and
DOX people not just any people but
miners as well not just any sort of
miner but teenage girls as well this is
a test for social media this is a test
for Twitter are you gonna take away that
guy's account I'm not saying you should
take away that guy's account necessarily
but if you're taking away conservatives
accounts you definitely have to take
away that guy's account and if you don't
then clearly this is not a level playing
field clearly this is not an open
platform and we should go and use every
single tool of the law at our disposal
to rip these guys to shreds to rip their
platforms
to shreds well they're a private company
don't care
sort they're sort of a private company
yeah they're sort of but there are
provisions of the law to protect
platforms there are different provisions
of the law for publishers the law is is
murky all shallows are clear but the law
is murky and we should go in there and
go after them because this is a warning
shot for 2020 that's what this is all
about this is why conservatives are
being kicked off of these platforms this
is why and Alexandria Ocasio cortes
parody account was taken off of Twitter
yesterday a parody account it said it
was a parody it said it was unaffiliated
with Alexandria Ocasio Cortez had
labeled itself very clearly it was taken
off meanwhile plenty of Donald Trump
parody accounts still are allowed to
exist
why was the AOC one taken down because
it's become pretty popular it had about
85,000 followers so they have to take it
down and this is a warning shot it don't
forget the year is 2019 presidential
election is in 2020 and what they're
doing is they're saying what happens if
we take away this kind of funny parody
account are they going to move for
they're gonna okay what happens if we
take away this Conservatives account
what happens if we take away this not
conservative but kind of right-wing and
he's pretty objectionable and we okay
what if we take away is are people going
to do anything to stop us and what this
is becoming is an in-kind contribution
to Democrats what this is becoming as a
platform for the promotion of Democrats
in political campaigns and if we don't
fight back now we're gonna find
ourselves at a severe disadvantage in
2020
speaking of political fights speaking of
war the Dow has been dropping five
hundred points today under a trade war
threat because President Trump is
ratcheting up tensions with China in
this trade war that were engaged in we
will analyze the case for protective
tariffs basically no conservatives are
defending tariffs I would like to make
the case for tariffs because I I'm not
say
that we need to have economic protection
I'm not saying free trade is a bad thing
but I think conservatives have become
very ideological they've allowed
ideology to blind them on this question
of tariffs and there are plenty of good
reasons to limit free trade there are
plenty of good arguments against free
trade we'll get into them in one second
but first go to daily wire.com ten bucks
for a monthly membership 100 dollars for
an annual membership you get me you get
the indra Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
you get another Kingdom and you get the
leftist tears tumblr mmm so delicious
Pete but a judge wham wham wham go to
daily wire.com we'll be right back with
a lot more
the Dow is down 500 points why because
the US and China might escalate their
trade war now this latest tension began
a few days ago when President Trump
tweeted out for 10 months China has been
paying tariffs to the USA of 25% on 50
billion dollars of high-tech and 10
percent on 200 billion dollars of other
goods these payments are partially
responsible for our great economic
results the 10% will go up to 25% on
Friday 325 billion dollars of additional
goods sent to us by China remain untaxed
but it will be shortly at a rate of 25%
the tariffs paid to the United States
have had little impact on product cost
mostly borne by China the trade deal
with China continues but too slowly as
they attempt to renegotiate no no sad so
when this threat came out from Donald
Trump the markets didn't really move
because they didn't really believe it so
that's more tweeting okay we'll see if
anything actually happens then when
China and the United States didn't come
to some sort of agreement over the
ensuing few days all of a sudden the
markets start to take this seriously
said gosh we really might get a trade
war now in the midst of all this Chuck
Schumer tweets out and says president
Trump stays strong on China that's the
only way to deal with them is to get
tough some people read this as Schumer
being sarcastic as Schumer saying yeah
keep up keep up those tariffs buddy
great job let the economy tanked and
then that way we'll sweep to victory as
Democrats in 2020 he actually wasn't
being sarcastic it's a sign of our times
that we assume any time a Democrat
agrees with a Republican that it's
sarcasm but Chuck Schumer has been
pretty consistent on this for a while
Chuck Schumer in 2005 led the push in
Congress to impose a 35% tariff on China
which is ultimately what led the Chinese
to allow their currency to weaken a
little bit Schumer is calling for a
little toughness on China
so is President Trump
the case for tariffs right now is
particularly geared toward China first
of all let's just point out that the
economy is doing very very well
President Trump has been saying it's the
best economy we've ever had in many ways
that's true were at 49 year lows of
unemployment average wages are up to 20
777 per hour we now have many many more
job openings than people who were
looking for jobs we've got we were told
by Barack Obama's economists that we
would never see 3% economic growth Larry
Summers chief economist to Obama said
that the predictions of 3% economic
growth were basically like wishing for
the Tooth Fairy he used that phrase the
Tooth Fairy and then what happened we
hit 3% economic growth by the second
quarter of President from first year so
we had 3% it rose significantly higher
than that in 2018 we again in just this
last quarter very very strong economic
growth so you can't simultaneously make
the case that Trump is this economic
idiot and his tariffs are destroying the
economy and also observe that we have
the strongest economy basically that
we've ever had so what is the case for
tariffs well on China the case is we're
already in a trade war we're already in
a trade war China is waging a trade war
they've been doing it for years and
years and we should be able to fight
back and we should fight back they steal
our intellectual property they illegally
manipulate their currency they illegally
subsidize their steel and aluminium
industries and they cheat on World Trade
Organization treaties China always
cheats when China was admitted to the
World Trade Organization in 2001 they
almost immediately began cheating and
they don't just cheat on the economic
front they cheat on everything during
the Obama administration China promised
us that they would not militarize the
South China Sea what happened they began
to militarize the South China Sea so we
know that they're cheaters we know that
they don't respect WTO treaties so the
case for tariffs now is it gives them an
incentive to start complying with what
they
should have been doing for years to not
steal our property not steal our
technology so if we put these tariffs on
and then we say we will pull back on
those tariffs if you comply with what
you're already supposed to be doing
that at least gives them some incentive
to comply
it adds real pressure not fake Obama
pressure like yes you better do it I got
a red line here's your red line China no
actual pressure because they are feeling
the effects of those tariffs if the
threat to China is going to have any
teeth on tariffs it needs to be a
serious case this I think is the the
issue that conservatives can get behind
conservatives are saying well tariffs
are always awful they're just terrible
but in a negotiation it helps you if you
seem half crazy warren buffett says this
too he says in a negotiation sometimes
you want to seem like you're totally
crazy you're a madman
you'll do anything even if it isn't
insane yes saying that Donald Trump he's
just playing the madman well I don't
know if it's just that I don't think
it's going to have very much teeth the
markets didn't move when it was just
Trump tweeting they moved today when it
looked like he was serious and there is
a serious case to be made for tariffs I
know this is a heresy I'm going to be
cast out of the Republican Party and the
conservative movement I will be thrown
into the outer darkness where there is
wailing and gnashing of teeth well too
bad because there actually is a case to
be made for tariffs to begin the
Republican Party was founded on tariffs
Abraham Lincoln was a staunch defender
of tariffs Abraham Lincoln said give me
a tariff I'll give you the best country
in the world
Daniel McCarthy made a good case for
tariffs Daniel McCarthy who writes for
modern age conserved a journal he points
out that tariffs a comp can accomplish a
few things first of all they can
accomplish the goal of maintaining
industries necessary for preventing
full-scale war so the idea with free
trade is look we don't need to actually
produce anything in the United States
because we're so rich and China has
Slave Lake
so we can just buy all of our goods from
China and it'll be cheaper and that way
we'll all save money okay fair enough
argument the issue is when you move all
of your industry to China what happens
when China declares war on you all your
free trade just broke down when you're
at war with the country you're probably
not trading very freely and now China
has all of your manufacturing capacity
you have no industrial capacity anymore
now you might have a lot of money but
where are you going to get the
industries necessary to wage a war that
goes away this came into play in
particular in the civil war this is in
no small part why the Republican Party
has always had some affinity and it's at
least in its early days for protective
tariffs in the civil war if the North
did not have an industrial advantage
would the North really have won the
North had a completely dominant
industrial advantage over the South what
if the South had industrialized are we
sure that the country would look like it
does today how been in World War two if
the US had not had industrial capacity
major industrial capacity in World War
two would there have been a Western
Front to that war don't forget the
United States was attacked by Japan were
fighting a war in the Pacific we are
simultaneously fighting a war in Europe
now why are we fighting the war in
Europe because if the United States
didn't come in Britain would have fallen
Winston Churchill's biggest strategy in
World War two is begging the United
States for help and to come in to the
rescue of the old world if the United
States didn't have massive industrial
production there's no way we could have
fought both sides of that war
who knows what have happened in Europe
this is one argument is it not
everything is just an economic chart I
think what people who worship at the
idol of free trade as though it's a good
unto itself they say well look look at
all of our economic charts right
economic charts break down in the real
world because countries aren't just
trading entities countries go to war
countries have diplomacy countries have
interests in other regions countries are
much more complicated than buying and
selling
t-shirts another reason another argument
for protective tariffs is the middle
class do we want a small elite or do we
want a giant base of rather a small
elite and a giant base of worker bees or
do we want a substantial middle class
now you might say Michael I don't care
who are you to decide where people
should fall in in economic strata who
are you to decide how much that big
middle class should be how big the upper
class should be how big the worker class
should be who what does it matter to you
if a very small number of people make an
insane amount of money and then
everybody else still does fairly well
but they have radically less money than
the elite I don't really care in
principle but I do care
politically so over the past decade two
decades wages among the middle and lower
classes have mostly flatlined wages of
the elites have increased tremendously
if that situation persists if it grows
if it's exacerbated you get political
revolution this almost happened in the
1930s this has happened in many
countries all around the world and
continues to happen today eventually you
get a revolution there look at the Met
Gala yesterday you saw this crazy
costume is this the Met Gala basically
shows us how the French Revolution
happened I think bunch of French
peasants thought are you kidding me
you're dressing like that and you're
eating that and you're behaving that way
we're going to burn down palaces and
behead our monarchs is but basically
what they're thinking the argument here
is that a stable economy requires a
stable political system now stable
political system requires a stable
economy so there's a there's a push and
pull here but it cannot be the case that
you've got one guy who's got all the
money and everybody else has radically
less money and you've got a stable
political system that is very unlikely
to happen and so it is in the interest
of the
often to have a thriving middle class
and and then the third case is economic
prosperity perhaps it is the case that
perfect free trade is not the only route
to national wealth every country has
protective tariffs the United States has
always had protective tariffs every
other country has them - there's a
reason for that it's because the economy
is complicated free trade is very clear
all shallows are clear the question
you've got to ask yourself is what is
the purpose of free trade is free traded
good in and of itself perfectly
unfettered free trade not just among
people in a country but but among people
in different nations is it the case that
an American defense contractor should be
allowed to have trade deals with any
foreign government with no regulations
whatsoever is it the case that American
defense contractors should be building
up China's army about in the 1930s
should American defense contractors be
building up Hitler's army how about
other foreign governments should they be
just tojust no question at all should
Americans be allowed to freely trade
with Iran we're not currently allowed to
do that we have sanctions on Iran how
about North Korea no what is the purpose
of free trade it's not an end unto
itself it is a means to an end and the
means that it is an end to is human
flourishing and in the United States
it's a means to American flourishing and
if free trade is not serving the ends of
American flourishing that's an argument
against free trade the left is very
ideological they they adhere to very
narrow ideologies that you can write
down on a little sheet of paper and have
bullet points boom boom boom boom here's
the manifesto here is leftism
conservatives are supposed to oppose
that because we know that reality can't
be rationalized into some silly little
doctrine reality is much more
complicated sometimes on this issue we
get a little too ideological and then
the other question is are we primarily
consumers this was always Milton one of
Milton Friedman's great arguments all
there's wonderful videos on YouTube
of Milton Friedman talking about free
trade and free markets he'll say look
everybody is a consumer you might be a
producer for eight hours of your workday
but then you come home and you're a
consumer and so if free trade means that
you lose a little bit of money on your
wages but you gain so much more money in
savings when you buy consumer goods
you've actually gotten a raise whether
you get the money from your employer or
you save the money when you shop at
Walmart either way you've got more money
in your bank account as a result of free
trade but this does get to another
question in society which is do we want
to be primarily consumers everybody's
both we're producers where consumers
were all those sorts of things but do we
want to have a consumerist society
consumerism is disgusting it's it's so
gross when you just walk around places
where people are only concerned with
material goods and getting a good deal
and buying the latest gadgets and just
buy buy buy consume consume consume
that's a disgusting culture do we want a
culture that replaces cathedrals with
shopping malls no how is that
conservative there's nothing
conservative about consumerism you need
to have a moral basis to to even
tolerate freedom and free markets and
free trade you need to have discipline
in yourself you need to not just become
this gluttonous materialistic culture
which sometimes is fed by worshipping at
the idle of free trade now there are
costs to tariffs so we just made the
case for tariffs there are costs to
tariffs tariffs usually mean less wealth
for everyone because it's basically the
government imposing a tax on its own
people the tax eventually is going to be
passed on to consumers that's the likely
outcome at least the other cost of
tariffs is it's the government choosing
winners and losers so the government
will go in and say okay we want to
protect the dairy industry but we don't
care about the soy industry or we want
to protect the soy industry but we don't
care about the paper industry and so
you've got the government going into the
economy and picking winners and losers
and unfortunately the
is very bad at organizing economies and
planning economies to precisely all true
strong arguments against free trade but
when President Trump goes up there and
he's negotiating with China he's trying
to get us a good trade deal he's trying
to get them to stop violating the trade
rules that they've already agreed to and
he tries to get them to stop stealing
all of our stuff he tries to get them to
stop illegally subsidizing their
industries when he threatens tariffs
there are plenty of good reasons for
those tariffs and more or less the
lesson2 conservatives here however all
the Conservatives are accusing each
other of not being true conservatives
capital T capital C trade mark /
conservatives the free traders are
saying you're violating free trade
orthodoxy which has been the bedrock of
the conservative movement for only like
35 or 40 years but never mind that and
then you've got the protectionist people
saying you free traders you're just a
bunch of neoliberal globalist modernist
what okay all I'm saying is a little bit
of a middle way here which is free
markets are generally speaking the most
efficient way to allocate goods and
resources in an economy economic freedom
free markets usually imply property
rights which are good in and of
themselves private property is necessary
to civilize society private property is
a moral good we should be able to use
that property as we like with relatively
few restrictions but we should not
become idolaters at the altar of the
free market there's nothing conservative
about that there's nothing smart about
that there's nothing highly intelligent
about that there's nothing politically
pure about that what happens when we do
that is we put the cart before the horse
and you you always you should ask
yourself this when it comes to politics
what is the purpose of this political
right what is the purpose of this
political institution was the purpose of
all we want to do as people is make
idols out of things make idols out of
the free market make idols out of voting
make voting is a great example of this
we make such an idol out of voting we
say you got to go out and vote puff
daddy tells me I got a voter die Bruce
Springsteen come out he says you got a
rock the vote doesn't matter who you
vote for just that you vote doesn't
matter if you vote it if you're
knowledgeable about events and you have
good judgement then you should vote but
voting is not a good in and of itself
voting is a means to an end
voting is a means to good government if
we could get better government by
restricting the vote great cool if we
could get better government by expanding
the vote great if we could somehow get
better government by expanding the vote
to include five-year-olds everybody five
years old and older can vote and then
that gives us better government fine
send the five-year-olds to vote if we
could get better government by limiting
the vote to people who are 50 and above
good I would do that too
don't make idols out of these things the
end is human flourishing and that and
that that's what we're all after and
everything else is just putting the cart
before the horse we got a lot more to
get to but ran out of time as usual get
your mailbag questions in for Thursday
we'll be back tomorrow in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show so if the Democrats
in the news media but I repeat myself
aren't going to talk about the booming
economy and they're not gonna talk about
the Obama spine scandal what are they
going to talk about the answer nothing
they've become the Seinfeld show
hilarious but about nothing we'll talk
about it on the Andrew Clavin show I'm
Andrew Clavin